Abby finds a family and Dan Fielding
finally achieves his dream but what will
season two of the new Night Court bring
us let's lay out the evidence
Abby Stone of course does not end up as
the Manhattan night court judge by
accident her father was the affable
magic loving judge Harry Stone the late
Harry Anderson played him for nine
seasons on the original Night Court by
taking over her father's old bench and
recruiting his former colleague Dan
Fielding to serve as public defender she
hopes to learn more about that time in
her father's life and perhaps she'll
learn more about herself as well as the
series begins Abby is in the midst of a
prolonged engagement with her
long-distance boyfriend Rand it's clear
from the start that something is out of
Step between them and when rant finally
makes the trip from their Upstate New
York small town to visit her in the big
city it's even more apparent that they
no longer fit into each other's lives at
first he is her Rock providing necessary
comfort as she struggles to fit into her
uncertain new position but by the end of
the season Abby has made the bench her
own and won over her cynical colleagues
with gumption and good cheer Suddenly
It's her future with Rand that is
uncertain
The Honorable Dan Fielding the two-part
season finale puts its characters at
personal and professional Crossroads as
the title suggests Dan has been offered
a judgeship back home in Louisiana which
Abby responds to in her typically
anxious and over-excited fashion she
plans a massive going away party that
she hopes will also function as a don't
actually go away party while trying to
ignore the fact that Rand feels
neglected the pressure is too much and
Abby acts out recklessly an attempt to
Aid an elderly defendant Louise lands
her in jail and facing a trumped-up
felony charge thanks to Weasley district
attorney Jeff DeWitt with Dan as her
attorney Abby faces the possibility of
disbarment and perhaps even jail time
for trying to help a little old lady
break into her boyfriend's nursing home
Dan pleads with her to let him foist the
blame on the wheeze but Abby refuses to
let someone else suffer for her actions
in the end she's saved by a slew of
character Witnesses who testify to her
Sterling character well that and the
fact that DeWitt coerced Louise into
wearing a wire the judge declares a
mistrial and Abby returns to the bench
Rand heads home to Upstate New York
after he and Abby finally come to terms
with the fact that they have Grown Apart
Dan meanwhile says his goodbyes to Abby
and to night court and he takes his seat
on the bench in rural Louisiana I'm not
being selfish
this is what I've always wanted I'm not
abandoning her
there's a lost in time aspect to the
Night Court Revival the sets all look
pretty much the same as they did in the
1980s and the cases called before the
courts are not much different everyone
has smartphones but they rarely figure
into the plot and the titular Tech
investment opportunity in the episode
past apps is merely the Catalyst for
Abby's ethical quandary in dealing with
an old-fashioned con man this is all
very much by Design When developing the
series producer Dan Rubin and production
designer Glinda ravello rated the Warner
Brothers television archives grabbing
surviving set decorations from the
original series and even using the
blueprints for the original courtroom
set to make sure the new one was to
scale the series nostalgic bonafides
don't stop at the set design though the
Revival is steeped in the same
Vaudeville energy that made the original
series a little old-fashioned even for
the 80s the show's insistence on warm
and fuzzy comedy that recalls a more
comforting era was very much a selling
point for Star Melissa Rausch she told
uprox I sort of like a it to a bit of a
time machine that can take you back to
that happiness as a result the show
largely steers clear of any divisive
real world issues regarding the criminal
justice system the fact that the
courtroom has barely been renovated in
four decades is arguably its sharpest
political gag
Dan's moved to Louisiana is a homecoming
in more ways than one actor John
Larroquette who won four Emmys in a row
for his portrayal of Dan on the original
series is from New Orleans and has kept
close ties to his hometown since leaving
for Hollywood in the 1970s in 2013 he
was even awarded an honorary doctorate
from the University of New Orleans
laroquette and his character share a
Louisiana upringing thanks to the
original Night Court writers who over
the years mined a lot of humor from the
idea that Dan the erudite Manhattan
attorney constantly trying to climb the
social ladder was born on the bayou and
raised in the possum filled Backwoods
the Revival keeps Dan's Pelican State
Birthright but takes it easy on the
redneck jokes it also keeps dance
womanizing past in the past during the
80s Dan was one of network TV's most
Shameless lotharios and his constant
pursuit of every woman in sight was one
of the original series most reliable
Wells of humor the episode that was
planned to be the series finale features
a nightmare sequence in which Dan is
Pride convicted and hanged by a
courtroom filled with every woman he had
ever slept with three decades on however
Dan is a changed man when Abby knocks on
his door in the pilot episode he's a
grieving widower the kind of man who can
no longer see himself being with any
woman much less Every Woman
that first scene between laroquet and
Roush in the pilot episode is heavy with
grief almost too heavy but that's a
burden that night court has had to carry
from nearly the beginning the show's
early seasons were marked by the deaths
of actresses Selma diamond in 1985 and
her replacement Florence halop just a
year later Abby's grief over her father
and connection to Dan as a surrogate
forms the emotional backbone of the
Revival given extra poignance by the
real-life death of star Harry Anderson
in 2018 the show Mourns not just a
beloved character but a beloved actor as
well for as much weight as Anderson's
death is given on the show however other
recent cast deaths are not mentioned at
all 2021 saw the deaths of both Charles
Robinson who played long-time officer of
the Court Mack and Marky post who joined
the show as public defender Christine
Sullivan in season three it's possible
that their character's absence will be
commemorated in season two but it's
possible that in the world of Night
Court Mack and Christine are still alive
the 1992 finale saw Christine leaving
the public defender's office for a
nascent political career while Mack
tendered his resignation in order to
fulfill his dream of becoming a film
director it could very well be that
Christine and Mack are simply too busy
in Washington and Hollywood respectively
to show up to court anymore
the untimely deaths of Anderson Robinson
and post cast a Paul over the Revival
series after all half the fun of Legacy
sequels like this is to bring back the
old cast for one last hurray other than
laroquet there's hardly any original
cast left but the show kept one trick up
its sleeve in the final moments of the
finale Dan takes yet another case of a
soon-to-be bride arrested for fighting
in the French Quarter during her
bachelorette party but when he looks up
at the defendant he sees a very familiar
face Fielding
hahaha
they made you a judge
take me back to jail yes it's former
Nightcore bailiff Roz Russell played by
comedian Marsha Warfield Warfield joined
the cast of The Original Series in 1986
after Florence hellop died earlier that
year the wisecracking raws was quickly a
fan favorite and her verbal sparring
with Dan often cut the egotistical
lawyer down to size in an interview with
variety published after the season
finale aired Warfield spoke to the
Bittersweet feeling of being back on the
set after so many years and without so
many of her colleagues overall though
Warfield was happy to be reunited with
larocet and to meet the new generation
especially lacreda the new bailiff in
town Warfield said of their conversation
I told her just do you baby just be you
and enjoy it and enjoy the ride Welcome
to Night Court
the last two scenes of the finale
represent a new status quo for the
series Abby newly separated from Rand
and exonerated on her felony charge
returns to the bench reinvigorated and
ready to hear the first of two hot dog
related cases Dan meanwhile has achieved
a long time career goal and has become a
judge himself presiding over case after
case of drunken New Orleans brawls if
laroquet remains a regular on the show
it seems unlikely that his Louisiana
interlude will last very long into
season two however it's possible that
sending Dan off to his dream job is the
show's way of bidding farewell to the
character with laroquette in a reduced
role for the next season the two-part
finale also spends a fair amount of time
with gergs and her career Ambitions
despondent over failing the bailiff
supervisor's exam she attends dance
going away party where her facility with
remembering names and faces impresses a
representative from Scotland Yard gerks
is invited to a training program in
London but after coming to Abby's Aid as
a character witness in her trial the
possibility of her moving overseas is
dropped and never mentioned again did
gergs really give up the opportunity of
a lifetime to help out Abby or will her
London Adventures be seen in season two
NBC renewed the series for a second
season in February 2023 just a few weeks
after its surprisingly strong Premiere
in a March interview with collider
Melissa Roush confirmed that the
writer's room had recently convened for
season two and were working on the next
batch of scripts no premiere date has
been set just yet but the expectation
was that night court would return for a
full season sometime in Fall 2023 the
wga strike however may have changed
those plans in May 2023 The Writer's
Guild of America called a general strike
over the lack of compensation for
television writers bringing most film
and television production to a halt
while some shows are continuing to film
during the strike without the input of
their writers many others have chosen to
shudder production until the strike is
resolved including Night Court depending
on how long the strike lasts and how far
into production season 2 was when the
strike was called the show may not
Premiere until later in the fall or
perhaps winter of 2024. Melissa Roush
who is a producer on the show along with
her husband instant is expected to
return for the second season along with
India de Beaufort Kapil tall walcar and
lacreda laroquet who is also credited as
a producer on the pilot episode is a
little more in doubt ran tan is leaving
but it's because I helped him gave his
life new meaning etc etc after the
finale aired Marcia Warfield confirmed
to TV line that she would be returning
as Roz for at least one episode of
season two so it stands to reason that
we will see Dan at the same time though
it's possible that laroquet may not
return as a regular cast member
there's one major character from the
original series that we're waiting to
see Richard Mull's goofball bailiff bull
Shannon was one of the show's breakout
Stars a kooky simpleton with a heart of
gold and the two-parter that was planned
as the original series finale bowl is
convinced that a pair of little old men
seen around the courthouse were in fact
space aliens stalking him for nefarious
purposes in the end his suspicions are
confirmed the little old men really are
aliens from the planet Jupiter and have
come to recruit bull to grab all the
things on the planet that the aliens are
too short to reach bull accepts his
Destiny and disappears from Harry's
office in a flash of Light 30 years
later Paul is apparently still on his
interplanetary Adventure no mention of
the character was made in the Revival
season and mole himself has long been
hostile to the idea of returning to the
show in 2013 when cornered by a TMZ
paparazzo in an LA parking garage he
flatly stated that if any Night Court
reunion or reboot were to happen he
would quote run in the other direction
still a lot can happen in a decade's
time and it's not unheard of for actors
to be lured back to beloved roles could
bull pop up in season 2 of The Night
Court Revival the answer so to speak is
written in the stars
foreign